the guard will not be participating in
valorant Champions Tour Americas which
leaves the league with only 10 teams and
it's left everyone wondering what the
hell happened
[Music]
alright so less than two months ago the
guard did this time to come and get a
shoot shock dark set up preemptively no
one home start gets placed
it's a nebula EU tries to hang on to it
but no it's Trent to find the final kill
it's been 471 days since the rookies
made it to Reykjavik but today is the
day where veterans qualify for VCT the
guard
your Ascension champions in the Americas
region they've consistently been one of
the best North American valorant teams
since they first exploded onto the scene
early last year but when they weren't
selected as one of the 10 partnered
teams in VCT Americas they collectively
made a very courageous decision some of
their players turned down offers from
partner teams just so the core of the
roster could stick together and try and
earn a spot in VCT Americas through
Challengers and the Ascension tournament
and they did exactly that but I'm here
today because the spot that those five
players earned was just stripped away
from them yesterday the valorent Esports
and a Twitter account posted this update
stating that the guard failed to meet
the deadline to agree to the team
participation for VCT Americas and as a
result they will no longer be
participating in the 2024 VCT America's
League they also added that no team will
be promoted and the league will only
field 10 teams next year so my initial
reaction to that was what the actual
it's why wouldn't the guard agree
to join the League after grinding
Challengers and Ascension for an entire
year players casters and coaches all
agreed that it doesn't make sense to
punish the players just because their
org kinda sucks and if you're wondering
why I'm saying that the org kinda sucks
well we also made a video when the guard
laid off a large chunk of their staff
earlier this year on Wednesday an
apparel designer for the god tweeted
about that quote everyone's position at
the guard has been eliminated Esports
and streaming reporter Hunter specified
that the layoffs had solely affected the
guards content social talent and
creative teams as the evening went on we
heard from more and more now former
guard employees sharing similar stories
of being abruptly let go from the org
with little to no warning perhaps the
most starter example came from Ariel Ben
Abraham who was the newly appointed GM
of apparel at the guard he said he moved
location for this job earlier this week
only to find himself unemployed two days
later so I though I was pretty pissed
off following yesterday's announcement I
wasn't entirely surprised to see a
cronky group owned the guard screw over
more of their employees but the fact
that players were left out of the loop
and were waking up to this awful news
through Twitter is a joke it's not fair
to the entire valorant team who works
their asses off to earn a spot in VCT
Americas BCT emea and VCT Pacific will
become 11 team regions with newly
promoted gentle mates and bleed while
VCT Americas will remain a 10 Team
league yesterday's announcement has
obviously sparked a lot of discussion
within the community but there are two
main scenarios that everyone keeps
floating around as possible solutions
the first one is that Riot should give
the players a chance to at least try and
get picked up by a more stable org who
they can represent in VCT America's next
year that way the players who earned
this spot can still play DSG might not
be the best candidate but even toast
wants to see them keep their spot like I
said any ore 100 take them and toast
would love to be the first one
like there's uh I just don't understand
the idea of no team there's an entire
year of events that they had to
get there the other scenario is that the
VCT slot goes to the Ascension runner-up
M80 it's the next best option if there's
really no way for players from the guard
to compete and a lot of the community
are questioning why Riot hasn't offered
them the spot instead Riot's decision to
proceed with only 10 teams in VCT
Americas essentially means that the
entire Challenger seasons in n a Brazil
and latim were just massive wastes of
time and might even scare more orgs away
from Valor 32 teams competed this season
for one spot in VCT Americas and now
nobody gets it if you're a tier 2 player
then it must feel pretty demotivating to
see what just happened to the guard but
as much as I'd like to on the guard
as an org Riot might also deserve some
of the plan according to this tweet from
Hunter yesterday Riot allegedly told the
guard that they would not be offered
team skins and they'd receive a lower
Financial incentive and less than 24
hours passed by before Riot's
announcement he also added that despite
this the guard would still have to meet
all the same requirements and
deliverables as the other VCT partner
teams I went back and checked Riot's
press release when they announced how
promotion to International leagues would
work and they stated that promoted teams
will have the opportunity to prove
themselves against the international
league teams during the VCT season
received similar benefits and an equal
chance to qualify into Masters and
champions I think a lot of us glossed
over the word similar back then but I
think now we know what Riot meant by
that we obviously don't know what the
revenue share will look like for these
skins but if promoted teams don't get
them then I imagine that's going to be a
pretty big blow regardless the guard
also posted an update yesterday
afternoon which basically just thanked
the players and staff but didn't say
much else but last night Leo Faria
tweeted out his much anticipated reply
to this whole Fiasco where he outlined
that the guard never continued with the
onboarding process following the
Ascension tournament after two months
and several follow-ups with the org Ryan
had came to this difficult decision he
also confirmed that ascended teams do
receive the same benefits as partner
teams except for those team branded gun
skins now a lot of people have been
asking what would happen if a free agent
team won Ascension and Leo also answered
this question he said that in that
situation the players would have an
opportunity to find an org to support
them but since players on the guard
became free agents after qualifying that
would open the door for the sale of VCT
slots which obviously isn't allowed and
I get what he's saying it would be dumb
if a free agent team earned a spot to an
international league without any sort of
financial backing and then some org just
swoops in and slaps their name on the
roster and claims the win as their own
but I also agree with people like my boy
will minder who want Riot to make an
exception for these players who got
screwed over by their own orc I know
that Riot doesn't want to bend their
rules but given the circumstances I
really hope that they reconsider this
decision I know some of the guys from
the guard and they don't deserve this
Riot can literally decide who they sign
with if they really want to and I have
no problem with punishing the guard
they've proven multiple times that they
don't belong in Esports but don't punish
the players for something that's
completely beyond their control
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock